In the last lesson, we saw the uniform kernel or the Parzen window kernel.
Another kernel that is used often is called the Gaussian kernel.
The Gaussian kernel can be written in this form,
where uT is the transpose of the vector of values of u.
D being the dimension of the space.
The kernel density estimate is then given by this expression here.
It is very similar to our previous expression,
except now we have used the Gaussian kernel, instead of the Parzen, Render,
or the Uniform kernel, to make the density estimate.
Remember, the kernel density, is an estimate of the shape of the distribution,
using now here, the sum of Gaussians surrounding each data point.
We are now going to investigate what happens if we change this parameter h.
The h in this case is called the bandwidth for the kernel density estimate.
Let's now switch to the IPython notebook,
to see what happens when we change the bandwidth.